what move does a current NBA player have
that you also want to perfect SGA I like
he bumps in the pan a lot and I think
I'd do that a little bit because I have
a little dunk on everybody LeBron's dunk
package James Harden just says step back
if I can get that in my bag because
Sicily is rap rally build a step spin
reverse between legs step back sure
shade JoJo's Alexander like his patience
patience crazy Paul George tween cross
like the kind of hesitation a little bit
DeMar DeRozan's turn around jumper the
honest Euro Step being on LeBron he
looked down at the ball and shoot him
probably Kyrie fade in the mid-range
probably just Clay's catch a shoot
listen to him step back since I'm a
lefty I take a little bit of James
Harden's between the legs across